[Music]
El Santo is one of the most dangerous
countries in the world
[Music]
everything about ms-13 is extreme their
motto is murder rape control the number
13 is used in induction ceremonies they
do things like kill 13 people rape
somebody for 13 minutes there was
something very unsettling about not
having obvious motive to commit all this
violence it is a hugely threatening
organization it's join the gang or be
killed by the gang once you're a member
you can never leave ms-13 was founded by
political refugees fleeing the violence
in our Salvador in the 1980s a gang that
really took off in America ms-13 is
american-made you wouldn't believe how
bad these people I think the Trump
administration have decided to really
hone in on ms-13 their violence the
threat to Americans there are people
these are animals so we're gonna take
care of it he's going to send back a
great deal of el Salvadorans we are
taking them out by the thousands so
there is support for the idea of sending
these violent criminals back and some of
those people are returning and it's
causing a problem in El Salvador again
[Music]
[Music]
getting on a plane to one of the most
dangerous countries in the world is a
bit daunting you're going in knowing
that this is a city completely run by
gangs just on the day we arrived there
were 23 murders in the first few months
of this year there were nearly 500
people who killed at the hands of ms-13
we went to a market and we thought this
would be a good place to kind of get
everyday life and on the surface of it
it felt like normal people going about
their business but then an armed police
car rolls by with people in the back
with pointed guns and suddenly it
reminds you that you're in a tense area
there were police everywhere and by 6
o'clock in the evening it was stunningly
quiet
it's almost like someone switched off
the lights and what was a kind of
bustling and busy area just turned
desolate within minutes
and suddenly there are no people on the
street the gang violence is so extreme
in certain parts of town that people
just don't risk walking around at night
the police are almost militarized in El
Salvador they have this extensive
program in the evening and where they go
out they patrol the streets looking for
evidence of gang activity
what was difficult for me was there was
constant chat about what they're looking
for people talking on the radio not
being able to understand them I had to
rely on kind of body language sense of
urgency how they're moving how they were
driving it's quite scary you are on
completely empty streets you feel the
threat of the police they're all decked
in navy blue holding enormous guns have
you lost any friends for friends killed
we felt patrolling around with the
police like you're sort of peering in
you felt like a bit of a voyeur and you
quickly were trying to imagine what it
was like living behind those closed
doors you felt under the spotlight they
went to a heavy ms-13 area there was a
bar there that was pretty bustling it
was about 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning
everyone was lined up against the fence
men and women and they were quite
intimately frisked and their reaction to
that wasn't kind of shouting and
screaming and saying I can't believe
you're doing this it was just quite
fatalistic really they just say okay the
cops are here out we go arms on your
head they didn't even really need to be
instructed on what to do so it felt like
quite a kind of regular event really
police say they believe that this is a
bar that's used by gangs and they're
searching these people to try and look
for any tattoos perhaps any drugs
weapons to anything that might show
membership to certain groups a big part
we actually thought will never get into
a prison and if we did get into the
prison I also thought okay we'll be
shown the model inmate but we won't
actually be shown the proper gang
members the guys who are essentially
running the prison
and running their gangs from inside the
prison we stumbled across another block
that we walked into we didn't realize
but that wasn't a place we were meant to
be an empty cell door just bars suddenly
is filled with guys just crawling all
over the bars they were literally
hanging off and kind of peering down at
us and there are just hundreds of
prisoners staring at us
it felt menacing in a way but I knew
they couldn't get to me or do anything
to me my job being to film them they
couldn't have been better
they were sandwiched together the light
was great they were covered in tattoos
it was kind of perfect and I was more
thinking about making the most of this
scene that I didn't think I would get
they were all crammed in there ms-13
tattoos everywhere all really menacing
looking guys I was very glad for the bar
that stood between us and then so you've
got like some guy kind of swinging on
his hammock kind of Deadeye another guy
with this kind of you know hands through
the bars it was really strong and
amazing pictures and actually was quite
weird looking at Cordelia pressed
against that front bar leaning on it
talking to them I mean she was inches
away from them
on the surface of it they looked very
threatening but they were willing to
engage as well they wanted to talk
how will they stop the gangs in El
Salvador of them had come from America
had said they'd been unfairly deported
were desperate to get back even though
some of them conceded that they
committed violent crimes
[Music]
we got wind of this young guy who'd been
killed out in the what you could call
the suburbs of San Salvador the capital
we pull up at this arid field we were
sort of a bit hesitant as we approached
didn't quite know what we're going to
find
in plain sight an 18 year old boy shot
dead for the first time I was witnessing
the reality of ms-13 and its brutality
so straightaway this felt like we had
got our example of gang-related violence
in El Salvador as tragic as it was that
was why we were there and then of course
it becomes very clear very quickly that
that sadly is this young man's mother
it's a sensitive situation a family
member is arriving at a crime scene
where a murder has taken place and I'm
between the dead body and the family
member and suddenly it felt like we were
really invading a private moment for a
family so what do I do this is part of
the scene I don't want to be intrusive
[Music]
it's really tough and and I did I did
film her and she saw me and I saw her I
didn't rush up to her but I didn't back
away either you're trying to illustrate
the gravity and level of violence that
this gang is capable of and the impact
it's having on families I'm very much
wrapped up in the moment of what's going
on as soon as my cameras to my eye then
I'm in that world of documenting what's
in front of me the body was kind of put
into a cellophane bag and literally held
onto the back of a pickup truck
the clunk is it hit the back was pretty
upsetting and then the mother beckons
over the policeman and he takes off
these worn down
trainers and he hands them to her and
she sort of takes them looking at them
like they're all she has left it was
just a kind of really shocking reminder
of the cheapness of life the tragedy of
El Salvador if you like is that you've
got this small number of people that
have committed crimes that are returning
to the country but you've also got a lot
of people who are being forced back
because they didn't carry out the right
paperwork
they are returning to a country that is
far more threatening than the one they
left
[Music]
the thing with gangs in El Salvador is
we came to learn is actually leaving
them is almost impossible as soon as
you're a member of the gang trying to
get out is really a death sentence in
and of itself
the gang recruits a lot of lost and
desperate people and they may turn out
to carry out the most horrific acts but
not all of them got involved to just do
that in the first place they got
involved because they felt lost
[Music]